foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our news here's your chance
to get the best news about your favorite
movies and Series this time you can look
forward to info regarding Fast and the
Furious 11 Mortal Kombat 2 and the next
Star Trek movie also first images of The
Wizard of Oz prequel Wicked and new
details about the Sonic series Knuckles
and the Twilight Saga we hope you enjoy
our video
Paramount plus is planning a new Star
Trek project called section 31. it was
originally supposed to be a series but
it has now been revealed that it will be
a movie instead the lead role will be
played by recent Academy Award winner
Michelle yo who already played Emperor
Philippa georgiou in the series Star
Trek Discovery according to variety the
storyline revolves around Philippa who
joins a secret branch of Starfleet this
is tasked with protecting the Federation
of planets at the same time she must
also deal with the sins of her past the
idea of the spin-off already existed in
2017 even before the first season of
Star Trek Discovery came out production
for the film is set to begin this year
Limitless and medium author Craig
Sweeney is in charge of the script for
Star Trek section 31 the movie will be
directed by alotunde ausun sanmi who has
already gained Star Trek Experience on
Discovery Michelle yeoh herself is also
among the executive producers production
will be handled by CBS Studios Star Trek
section 31 is one of the latest projects
in Paramount Plus's revamped start track
era just recently the third and final
season of Star Trek Picard ended in
March it was further announced that a
show about Starfleet Academy had been
Greenland plus it was revealed that both
Star Trek strange new worlds and Star
Trek lower decks will be continued and
that Star Trek Discovery will end with
its fifth season in 2024. we are eagerly
awaiting more news about the new Star
Trek movie with Michelle yo and we'll be
sure to keep you posted
more than a year ago Sonic the Hedgehog
2 was released and became the most
successful video game adaptation to date
despite the fact that the new Super
Mario Brothers movie can now claim this
title as its own many fans are waiting
for Sonic the Hedgehog 3 which has
already been confirmed but first there's
more to come in the form of a series it
revolves around Sonic's friend Knuckles
who along with Jim Carrey's character Dr
Robotnik is regarded as an absolute fan
favorite as variety reported earlier
this week production of the spin-off
series which was already announced back
in February of 2022 is progressing
nicely the official announcement about
the start of filming was made via
Twitter by director Jeff Fowler who also
directed both of the Sonic the Hedgehog
movies the shared image shows among
other things the typical cowboy hat that
Knuckles wears in the 1996 animated film
a signature feature of the red Echidna
varieties report also reveals that much
of the cast is now set unsurprisingly
actor Idris Elba can once again be
looked forward to also known from the
films are a Pally as Wade Whipple and
Tika Sumpter as Maddie Wachowski in
smaller roles there will be Knives Out
actress Edie Patterson Ted lasso actress
Ellie Taylor and Game of Thrones star
Rory McCann likewise joining the cast is
rapper and actor Kid Cudi who will play
an as yet unknown supporting role
according to the official synopsis the
series will involve Knuckles training
weight as his Protege and showing him
how he true Echidna Warrior fights the
start date of the knuckles series on the
streaming service Paramount plus is
currently undisclosed but we hope to
have more news about the ongoing
shooting soon
the legendary action franchise Fast and
Furious is about to move on to its
concluding phase ahead of the release
date of Fast X it has now been revealed
who will direct Fast and Furious 11. as
variety reports Louis laterrier will
once again be the director he already
took over from director Justin Lin for
Fast and Furious 10 who left the project
as a result of creative disagreements
the pressure full of terrier was high as
the movie is supposed to be the start of
the end of the story about Don Toretto
and his family the director already
implied that part 10 will end with a big
Cliffhanger all the more fitting that he
is now also taking over the grand finale
Fast and Furious 11. and hence it is
likely that the entire project will seem
as if it was made from One Piece the
terrier doesn't skimp on using big words
in a statement to Empire magazine he
said there's a war Brewing there will be
some tremendous casualties you will feel
all the feels tears Will Roll so fans
can look forward to a gigantic finale
that is sure to stir their emotions we
are excited to find out whether the
movie will be able to deliver on this
promise for now things will kick off
with fast 10 on May 19 2023 a release
date for part 11 has not been set yet
this week there was the first big piece
of news about the upcoming Mortal Kombat
sequel from Warner Brothers as geek
Vibes Nation first reported last week
filming is expected to start in June and
run until September it didn't take long
for the filmmakers to react producer
Todd Garner confirmed the start of
filming in Australia saying that he had
been wondering why he had had an
apartment down under the project is a
sequel to The Mortal Kombat movie
released in 2021 it didn't do very well
with the masses but still managed to win
over a few fans another scoop about the
project comes from that hashtag show
which has uncovered more details it
involves various characters that are to
be added in Mortal Kombat 2. among them
are two fan favorites from the game
series namely Shao Khan and Baraka Shao
Khan is the ruler of outworld and will
play the role of the main villain Baraka
on the other hand is a warlord with
razor sharp teeth who is initially
hostile but eventually joins the popular
Johnny Cage in battle also featured as
Princess katana who rules over the realm
of adenia and puts the fear of God into
her opponents with her steel fans she
will be particularly targeting Shao Khan
after he was responsible for her
father's death as that hashtag show
reports her parents Jared and sindel
will also play a part of the sequel the
last character mentioned in the article
is Quan Chi a demon who uses black magic
and necromancy against his enemies we
are looking forward to the upcoming
shootings in a few weeks and can't wait
to hear further news about Mortal Kombat
2. a release date is not known yet
fans of The Twilight Saga have a reason
to celebrate a series of adaptations of
Stephanie Meyer's best-selling book
series is in the works as The Hollywood
Reporter points out the project is still
in the early stages and is being
developed by Lionsgate television the
Twilight series will be scripted by
Sinead Daly who has previously worked on
popular series such as The Walking Dead
World Beyond Raised by Wolves and the
get down sources report that Daly is
working closely with Lionsgate TV to set
the specific direction of the Twilight
series that is whether it will be a
remake of the books and movies for
example or become more of a spin-off
book author Stephanie Meyer is also said
to be involved in the new adaptation the
Twilight movies produced by Summit
entertainment an Associated company of
Lionsgate have grossed more than 3.4
billion dollars worldwide a total of
five movies starring Kristen Stewart
Robert Pattinson and Taylor Lautner were
released currently there is no known
platform for the Twilight series The
Studio wants to develop the series
further before looking at where when and
how it will be launched
The Wizard of Oz from 1939 was not only
one of the first color films ever made
but is now also one of the most absolute
Classics of film history not quite as
famous as the musical Wicked the untold
story of The Witches of Oz from 2003. in
contrast to the original the Broadway
prequel to The Wizard of Oz is aimed at
an older audience Hollywood has been
working for many years on bringing
Wicked to the big screen and presenting
it to a larger audience this week after
a long period of uncertainty we finally
got to see the first images of the film
adaptation director John M Chu who
previously directed The acclaimed crazy
Rich Asians shared two pictures via
Twitter as well as information about the
featured actresses they are the two pop
stars Cynthia arivo and Ariana Grande
who will play the leading roles of el
Faba throb and Glinda Upland while
during the course of the story Glinda
develops into the Good Witch of the
North El Faba becomes the Wicked Witch
of the West thus two interesting and
above all opposing characters are the
focus of the story to director Chu
promoted the film and even stated that
both leading actresses had had great
influence on him personally the voices
of the two musicians are said to have
the potential to uplift to break hearts
and to render speechless so it seems
that the standards set by those in
charge are very high you can get a first
impression of Ariana Grande's
performance from a leaked video of the
filming which was posted by
Entertainment Tonight and others at the
beginning of the week by the way the
story about the Two Witches will be
shown on the big screen not in one but
in two parts you can expect to see
Wicked part 1 starting on November 27
2024 while Wicked part 2 will be
released on December 25th 2025.
that's enough from us now it's your turn
what news has impressed you the most
this week tell us and everyone else
about your thoughts in the comments for
those who want to get more information
we have also released a video about the
Super Mario Brothers movie feel free to
like this video and we'll see you next
week for more Hollywood news take care
[Music]
foreign